this reservoir supplies Capetown with
most of its water but after four years
of drought there's very little of it
left the TV artist cliff dam is only 10
percent full these trees were once fully
submerged louis stafford is director of
water funds that nature conservancy
south africa as a local she's acutely
aware of the water shortage in the
region normally where we stand would be
water and this is desperate times and
it's a result of climate change
population growth and it's a reality
that we will be well we see in in Africa
and in South Africa more and more and
the big question is when you look at
this you think how is this possible and
will it ever rain again and if it rains
will ever fill up this dam again even
the water withdrawal points have been
left high and dry they need to be filled
with the help of pumps otherwise the
pipes would remain empty Cape Town is
around 100 kilometres south of the
reservoir water scarcity is a fact of
life for the city's 4 million residents
restrictions on water consumption have
been in place for months
residents are limited to 50 litres of
water per person per day in the inner
city many people get their supply from
natural sources of water but hundreds of
thousands of people also live on the
outskirts of the city
Galen johannes isn't well off and has
always been economical about water
consumption there's no swimming pool in
the yard and just one tap in the kitchen
her family takes care not to waste a
drop of water the people yet in our
world they are very pleased precisely
because of the water that's being waste
like children's playing with the water
throwing everyone weight in the street
and I also learned my child to never
waste water because of the water
districts that is he are very highly but
thanks to the water shortage
Galen has found a job a water
conservation project was recently set up
close to her home she and a few other
local women now go to work every morning
it's a good opportunity for us there's
high unemployment in the community and
this is an opportunity for us to
generate an income for our families it's
hot the Duma recommends cup the women
clear shrubs from this huge wasteland
rainwater and treated domestic
wastewater seep into the Atlantis
aquifer after filtering through the sand
for three years the groundwater is
returned to the city's water supply
system but there's a problem non-native
plants like invasive Australian acacia
if you look at the structure of the
plant it's much bigger than the local
fine balls and the root structures or
the rooks root systems are quite big in
a relation with a plant so lots of water
gets sucked up through the roots and
evaporation evaporation takes place
through the leaves and the other way
that we're losing water is when it rains
and the plants are this they densely
packed together the water doesn't reach
the aquifer floor and they doesn't
replenish the aquifer experts say that
in the Cape region alone invasive plants
consume around 38 billion liters of
water a year enough to supply Cape Town
for two whole months the lowers to to
the ground we have to make it a little
bit
sodid you can see it's why we're using
this poisonous how does it bounce our
game
weed killer destroys the invasive plants
and stops them from spreading in
consuming valuable groundwater it will
take 30 years to kill off the occasions
for good the project is financed by the
water fund for Cape Town
Louise Stafford hopes it hasn't come too
late and all the hard work is pointless
if it doesn't rain we need to change our
relationship with water we need to
change the way we see these water supply
areas and then we need to change the way
that we work with nature and we need to
do everything possible to work with
nature to make nature more resistant to
resist them in these circumstances
otherwise we're facing a total collapse
you